and i believe we are live can you hear
me
all right let's hope youtube isn't
[ __ ]
hey what up people uh just brief audio
check can you hear me like is my voice
all right
is the volume appropriate
yeah there's a cat sleeping behind me
wait where do i turn
good
all right
yo
all right good well the i cannot do
anything about the pops yeah [ __ ]
uh
yeah that must be youtube i tested
everything so the volume should be fine
all right what up people
um
yeah
right so people uh
to start asking questions just at me
with the question if if you can and uh
or you can also use the super chats
those will have priority if i miss your
question then just keep spamming it
essentially
until i do get to it
yeah because the chat is uh wait see if
i can
uh
talk about timestamps yeah see if i can
okay good yeah uh all right so i'll be
i'll be uh
scrolling up and down in on my chat and
i'll be answering questions from now on
hey someone from hamburg nice to nice to
see you
and uh right so the first one i see is
my favorite train
oof that's a i don't think there's a
short answer for that
my favorite train
i suppose the like deutsche band's new
uh like those intercity electric
multiple units those are super cool and
the right reactions of course those are
super fun
yeah
but of course you know the
proper train for the proper occasion as
they say
why do your videos keep getting taken
down ah i don't think they keep getting
taken like there's there's like the
dubai video got taken down because i
used some like copyright uh
copyright [ __ ] it did like the bucharest
footage in it
but then not just bikes told me that uh
like that that same company built him
out for like hundreds of euros to use a
few seconds of their footage and i just
put it in the dubai video for free so of
course yeah that was those values so i
took the video down
yeah and uh let's see
once again if you have a question it's
just just at me because then i can like
like my
me being at it kind of highlights
on my end so i can keep track of it much
better otherwise it's just like a big
you know wall of text
what's your zodiac uh
yeah yes
and have you visited the us i have never
been to the us i don't know for better
or for worse i would i would be i'd be
interested actually
uh
wait
[ __ ] hell i could scroll down and the
thing puts me back in the middle
uh
let's see
what do you think what encouraged me to
start my channel
wait there's one before that what's the
name of your cat well the one behind me
is uh
what
surname is sleepyhead currently uh
and uh so what did what encourage
what encouraged me to start my channel
well it was just i felt like i had
things to say and i want to say them
um
that was basically it and uh
let's see but yeah that's that's what i
tell you that is what happened basically
i was just like damn is this
i've i am one opinion opinionated
jackass
i should uh do something about it you
know just like let it all out and so
youtube channel and it worked out
turns out my opinions are not that bad
according to my audience anyway
and what's my middle name well
my middle name is
anything
uh let's see
so
among us or among us i've never played
it so it looks like a fun game i might
try it yeah at some point and the
current political situation in austria
oh now we're getting to the uh
sort of hot and heavy questions uh
uh well austria like yeah basically um
so austria is like a multi-uh layer
problem austria is pretty like for those
of you don't know austria is kind of
like
a right-leaning
tread gone-ish uh country uh vienna is
progressive though like these cities are
rather progressive but um but otherwise
um
not really and so there was this sort of
uh treadcon
far-right alliance in austria that was
the
the uh ufop the
folk spot
and the
fry heights
i don't know how they're called like the
austrian freedom party fba which was the
far right party and this was to be the
first sort of big alliance in uh in uh
of the treadcon right in the far right
that it didn't [ __ ] work uh because
the
the far-right party's leader got busted
trying to
take a bribe from the supposed russian
oligarch's daughter who turned out to be
a journalist and they he promised like
lucrative contracts etc and now in
austria like the the like so that left
the the the normal rights
chancellor in power alone basically and
then
um
this meant that uh
like so he he took over basically and
lots of voters went over and then he
[ __ ] up like because there's a big
corruption scandal in austria it's gonna
be more more the same basically so the
chancellor is gone but in the same
politics then i'm gonna read a super
chat right now from chris das
uh what made you what made you equate
neo-classical architecture with white
supremacy uh what made
what made me equate it well
there's no okay so the two are not equal
so like um
i think i wasn't equating them rather i
was uh pointing out that there are
sort of there's sort of considerable
interplay uh between the two
uh well not my well neoclassical
architecture how was the
yeah
phrasing
architecture well
it's mostly just i would say classical
architecture like there's definitely an
overlapped it's like like the two
bleeding to each other or rather
modern the modern far right
has kind of seized aspects of that
aesthetic style
which is based on a false assumption i
know that oh lots of people are still
super salty about that statue video but
you know
i love it still
uh under super chat
uh
it's a gif with or gif depending on
where you're from
uh super cute
so thank you thank you tim bruns
right so on with the chat now
and once again super chats take priority
so if you want to make sure that i
answer your question then uh
then feel free
uh right would i do a meeting great in
vienna uh i i don't i don't uh live near
vienna so i don't think so that would
need chord that would require some
coordination and be actually being there
physically which is currently not the
case
so why do you support ukraine in the war
in donbass how do you feel about the
ultra-nationalism and the neo-nazism of
both sides oof that's a heavy question
um
so i don't think that um sort of
ukrainian neo-nazism is a threat to
anyone
uh outside of ukraine even even within
ukraine they're not really like it's
it's not like you know the [ __ ]
neo-nazi party has 25 in parliament no
no no
um
there's like one party i believe the the
the uh was it the radical party or
something which has like five percent i
can't recall right now i should look it
up
uh but
uh i don't like this the neo-nazi
problem is not really a a um
a severe problem this the problem is not
as severe as people make it out to be
like i am familiar with the situation it
is a problem it's just that it's just
not
only it's not really uh
i would say it's a bit blown out of
proportions that's not to say it doesn't
exist
um yeah so
why do i support ukraine like because
it's a democratic european country under
attack by an autocracy essentially
so i i feel like that should be an that
should be a no-brainer that's why that's
why by the way that's why i was a bit
mad at like three arrows and that's why
i said what i said in the wash
discussion
uh because
well basically i mean
to to not like this is a very clear
conflict to take sides in
and it tells a lot about you
what side you take here so like it's
it's
like it's it's very rare that you get a
situation which is that clear cut
that you got basically a basically a
a democratic country after a revolution
invaded by like budget basically so
you know
anyway
so uh let's see
what's your middle name i think yeah i
think you asked me this question already
uh my name my middle name is anything so
it's adam anything something
uh that's how you that's how it goes uh
i got two super super chat cinema three
so projects in the meantime thank you
very much guys uh
one is blank well thank you for the five
dollars
honor crown super chat uh from yiti
crazy by the way the previous one was
from
liquid lathe so thank you very much five
dollars
uh yiddi kretsi or
because that's how he checks but it
thoughts about czech election and
president well
pretty soon you know
um pretty soon zemen will uh you know
you'll be the
formerly
i guess formerly alive president uh
like based on just how much harm that
[ __ ] dude has done to the world and
to the czech republic i'm it's the same
[ __ ] as that as like hassan and rush
limbaugh like i'm gonna be [ __ ]
celebrating when zeman dies
holy like i i i it's hard to it's hard
to find a person
more damaging to [ __ ] like liberal
democracy than [ __ ] middle zaman and
the czech election was generally cool
um i i'm glad that uh i'm glad that anno
and bobby got defeated bobby she's
basically like check trump who has been
in power
um
yeah so that's that's uh we'll see how
it will go i'm hopeful still
next donation from uh steven and nila
uh would you rather live in shanghai or
dallas texas um
damn well i guess i would live in dallas
texas and you know go from there i i
don't like tech dystopias like china so
thank you stephen
uh next one from an uh anthony mateos
pereira
my nice name adam do you plan on doing
something south latin america related
i'm sudaka myself and i love your
content i would love to see your
opinions on things uh yes i i might
actually um that's that's a topic that i
have not explored yet
uh so yeah we expect it sometime in the
next six years but yeah i will do
something definitely
about it so thank you for the donation
uh next one is from team bruns again
what is your education well i have a
bachelor's degree uh i'm a linguist by
trade so um
that's my that's my education i'm a i'm
a
university educated libcock like the
rest and i hate western civilization
um
so i don't actually so the next donation
a hundred shekels from pierre anderson
uh have you heard of the vault europa
party yes uh they're the federalists if
i believe i have not dug into the that
much i know that after after the
federalization video like after the
let's fertilize europe video a lot of
people
um
reach out to me like hey do you know
about vault i was like no not really i
haven't encountered them yet but i
looked at them and they they seem cool
so
uh although you know if it turns out
tomorrow that they you know
that they sacrificed children to the
devil you know and then you got me on
video saying oh they're cool you know
that's uh so based on what i've
been sent i like them and i think i
think i would support them so thank you
for the donation
uh 300 rubles uh from vladimir koscielny
thank you very much i love your videos
thank you for your work you're welcome
uh and well you know i do this for fun
and i'm actually i'm also glad that you
are here and all of you here so
uh this is a two-player game
it's not just me it's about you guys too
quiet queerty five zero donation thank
you very much what is our opinion on the
nordic council
um
that's i cannot i couldn't give you i
would need to
get more into it to to give you a full
for response but but i will i will
actually uh
i'll actually i'll actually get into it
uh currently i cannot give you like a
like a
in good faith a full answer because i
just don't have enough information for
that but thank you for the question
and five pounds from ben uh what are
your favorite genre of movies if you
mind me asking that of course um of
course not uh thank you for the
thank you for the donation ben um my
favorite genre of movies
i suppose um
i like i guess like detective movies
those are always fun
and um
also like action if done well
a fantasy but
fantasy has to be really really well
done for me like i i i don't just i
don't just just uh
um
sort of
go into anything like i i have mixed
feelings about the witcher i liked the
the lord of the rings movies
um
so i like harry potter for example so i
like all of those
uh otherwise
um
yeah what i don't it's easier to
the easier answer is what i don't watch
which is like rom-com and and stuff like
that i just don't like those yeah
documentaries too like those are fun
uh luis perez asks for five pen
i
i don't know what currency that is but
thank you hi really you are really
handsome wow thank you uh and what is
your opinion on historical and
archaeological heritage treatment and
public urban planning good and bad
examples
i would need a clarification on that uh
uh his historic archery treatment well
it depends on what country you know in
spain there's like a big
there's like a big uh you know i guess
unofficial movement of people complete
amateurs
restoring um
uh archaeological uh relics which
usually doesn't end well
um
so i mean if as as long as it's done
well then yeah sure and uh
and public urban planning i guess what
you're referring to is is people
uh people getting into the planning
themselves no no so this
if if this is what you mean so that
things are planned with the people who
are actually who actually live there and
are involved there then i think it's a
good idea of course you wouldn't want
like
people just like nimbying the [ __ ] out
of a neighborhood
uh so as long as local planning is kept
within reason
like people aren't trying to like
you know move water remains where
they're not supposed to be etc then i
think it's like there's a there's a
middle ground there
um
one more donation from uh
kind of ryan for shackles thank you
should the original aromas that should
be painted or should copies be
accompanying the originals painted
them yes i would say the second option
so um have the original there and then
just like copy next to it make it very
very visible that hey
uh you know this these things were
painted so it's it's it's to make the
statement and to raise awareness
basically
uh right
minhas uh what are your thoughts on
justin trudeau and what's your favorite
public transport system so far could be
anywhere on this planet uh well justin
trudeau like i don't
i don't know as much about canadian
political system to
just like like that like uh for me to
jump in both both feet but um
the thing is uh he just as far as i know
he's just this like
he's just like girl boss yay i mean
neolib
pro or progressive et cetera like your
usual like you know
algorithm generated center right
politician um
more that's more than that i cannot say
right now
and um what's my favorite public
transport system so far
i think my favorites like i have my
multiple favorites paris that's a big
favorite tournament it's super cool
uh also
uh i would say uh tokyo that's uh the
the rail system is is super good the
what's not so good about that is that is
that there are different operators so
like you buy one ticket and then you go
down it's like and it's a different
ticket and you like just unified dude
come on
uh yeah so tokyo uh paris and also
prague but prague has a super nice
network too
uh yeah so those would be my
my favorites
berlin is also super nice of course the
s-bahn
so next uh donation from chris dance
again what do you think of destiny the
streamer oh i like destiny like i watch
your stuff often i would say wait are my
headphones symmetric
sorry ocd
good yeah so i like destiny i like his
stuff i like his debate style his his
debate with no [ __ ] oh my [ __ ]
god that's those pure gold so after
after this live stream feel free to
check out like destiny's like destiny no
[ __ ] debate
and uh destiny's jontron debate jesus
[ __ ] christ that's that's comedy gold
i like destiny so i've never met the
dude but you know still i'll watch him
so next one from shia madan
400 i believe these are rupees
can you suggest books other materials on
urban policy and concepts like right to
the city uh i would say like a good
beginner type book or like a good uh
book to get into it would be
uh walkable city rules uh from jeff spec
and uh yeah that's that's i think that's
that just summarizes everything and it's
a it's a good start it illustrates it's
tough so so once again that's walkable
city rules from jeff spec
uh i can recommend it for to everyone
and the next one from benedict's nine
nine one five when in the currency of my
dearest home country god help me uh
so benedict's 915 asks adam something
what's your take on the hungarian
opposition primary this september do you
think orbit could be overthrown [ __ ]
yeah uh i i was so looking forward to
that like in hungary
uh fides basically changed the electoral
laws so that the entire opposition had
to congeal into one like these are
this is like every party to like every
non-urban party together it's super
crazy and now they are together
and
they're like multiple opposition
candidates and the one which is
palatable a center-right dude but but
pretty cool uh he won the opposition
internal primary and so he basically he
was the only person who was going to
stand a chance against orban in april
next year when that's when hungarian
elections are and he actually won the
primaries like the opposition primaries
in which fides of course didn't take
part this is entirely fully just
organized by organized by the opposition
so [ __ ] yeah i think orban definitely
can be overthrown we'll see we'll see
you next year
uh next one
from
geronimo
ramirez
sending me a thank you emoji and well
thank you too for watching that is
uh next one quickly uh from ben under
the question five pounds thank you very
much another question what is your
source of motivation to carry on
producing such videos especially to the
extent you go
do you go to per video i just like doing
it um it's for me it's a hobby and i
don't i don't really
i don't really um think of it as work
and i don't experience it as work i
experience it as like something that i
really want to do and it's it's really
like to see a video coming come together
in front of you it's just like super
nice plus i get to say my piece so i
think for me it's like
for me it's like
i think i think for me the the day i'll
i'll i'll stop youtubing will be the day
when i when this when it no longer gives
me such joy and it when it will start
feeling like work so
um
yeah so yeah
um
very quickly liquid
liquid let's see there's also 10 euro
donation but the smaller ones uh they
expire faster so i'm going to quickly
read through this and then i'll go on to
black cast 33
liquid
liquid led okay
five dollars thank you uh
blank on accident law why the tangents
like 420 k raise
thunderous changes uh
yeah those are ironic of course uh and
they refer to this like um
this like elon musk
reddit bro
kind of thing you know it's like
it's meant as a parody so like i don't
take that seriously like i'm making fun
of people like that and when i say that
and so next question from blackest 33 3
10 euros thank you very much
on the subject of european federation we
have
a big
big problems of technological
independence for example we depend on
american cpus intel amd software what do
you think well i would just
i'm of the opinion that like [ __ ]
nationalize the internet
like if you think about it it's like
you know uh
it makes like i want internet to be like
water from floating from the tap so i
would i would say like heavy national
provider
which is overseen by taxpayers so so
they cannot like throttle your
connection and like you know
this would ensure
neutrality and i would also have some
kind of like
heavier state involvement in chip
manufacturing because these are vital
parts of our lives at this point and
they cannot just you know they won't
just go away next up from chris does
again since you like destiny like i do
always forgiven for this statue video
lol all kidding aside me political enjoy
videos girls thank you very much i'm
glad you enjoyed my stuff uh am i and
i'm so glad you forgave me now i'll be
able to sleep
so
uh
a thousand thousand for instantiation
from gabor di chair hi i love your
content do you watch jordan peterson
[Applause]
wow
yeah
i did at some point
but now i don't watch him for the reason
you think
uh actually i i'm considering putting
out a video on jordan peterson so uh
you know because i i do believe he's a
he's a mr grifter like this is full-on
uh you know [ __ ] jordan peterson
uh oh god no no no i'm going to [ __ ]
like talk about him for like two hours
if i don't catch myself anyway so if i
see to say jordan peterson is like
uh to summarize him there's this meme of
like
of like uh you know his his he's got
this whole cool new ideas like christian
conservatism which is basically that's
what he's peddling like he puts forwards
these like really vague ideas
but if you look at it like all his ideas
point to
christian conservatism you know like his
takes on immigration like like
you know or
leftists say just let him in help people
and uh right-wingers say wait you don't
know what you're letting in
okay and you know uh i don't believe in
god but i i live my life as if i like
okay i'm i'll i'll stop trying to
pretend
uh to uh imitate him
hassan i began to do it much better
and
so yeah all his all his talking points
all his ideas all his rhetoric points
towards
christian conservatism basically so um
yeah well
i guess uh
young disaffected
doomers are a big market
out there
okay so uh moving on though uh timu uh
thank you for the five year donation do
you think a federal europe should have a
common nuclear weapons program or do you
think that having france is the only
supervisor enough i'd say that's a good
question actually i haven't considered
that
but i suppose like since i advocate for
a
european army it makes sense that the
nuclear armaments would also be under
some sort of some sort of common control
of course i'm not sure if i'm not sure
if this should mean
that you know now [ __ ]
i don't know uh
poland has control over i don't know
france francis also has control over
france's nukes uh it's a difficult
question but that like i i don't think
nuclear weapons at that point would be
just left up to the nation states so
yeah but it's a very interesting
question i never never actually thought
about this so thank you
uh next super chat from anan 5 heroes
thank you very much
would it be weird if i wanted you in my
room having all the coconuts well
it wouldn't be weird actually i offend
thumbs about it all the time
alright so now we don't have any super
chats so i'm gonna be back to the chat
now i jump i'm jumping down like crazy
so if you ask your questions like you
know half an hour ago then i will not
see that unfortunately
by the way we have a super chat again
quickly really quick like uh ben again
for five pounds what is your opinion on
the united kingdom's current government
in a brief statement
in a bri in a brief statement uh so my
opinion on the
current british government is like
what
basically
so
there's this that's all i wanted to add
uh [ __ ] boris johnson
um
oh
right so there's also a super chat
asking me to say something in hungarian
uh boiler
yeah i i i don't want to speak hungarian
because like that's that kind of closes
out 99 percent of my audience
uh so
i'm back to the chat flow now uh i'm
seeing questions about what do you think
about the sncf the the uh
the uh the french railway of you know
i've taken the tj so far they
i think you know french people complain
about it i think they're fine of course
i'm from a i'm coming from an eastern
european perspective so you know for me
like for me fine means something else
but whatever
yeah they're fine i guess uh what do you
think of the all of shorts and the
traffic light coalition
um
well
i think it's i think it's better than
than than the previous to the utsu
mainly because um like not many people
know this but actually they said they
would csumerco's coalition
uh
was um a big sort of
uh
i guess allower like uh
big
they were like standing or bound
hardcore because orban
lowered the taxes for german car
manufacturing companies and so you know
the conservatives
you know are now outside all of shorts
and there is like there are there are
plenty of sort of
more conservative leading people in
their ranks but i think it's gonna be
generally better um
there it was and that's actually part of
a larger tendency of of all these all
these um
uh
traditional conservative parties
basically just like
falling into oblivion about which i'm
going to be making a video essay at some
point it's a very interesting process
but what what's not so nice though like
that's that's nice like conservative
party is receding a bit what's not so
nice
is uh
what will come instead of them
and i'll be exploring this in a future
video we get a super chat in the
meantime uh gandalf tv gander for the tv
channel i didn't know that uh for uh 25
zlotys i think pln is lucky or the slot
uh the polish currency
uh what is your opinion on the current
situation in poland ha called it um
especially in context of the recent
debate in u.s congress best wishes from
turkey um
right so
poland is [ __ ] insane like we got we
got our first death in poland uh
from like uh from like doctors refusing
to carry out an abortion which threat
which was life-threatening to the woman
and you know
the fetus was clearly not the the way
the way i understand it the fetus was
clearly not viable
they they they uh but they didn't they
couldn't save the woman's life because
they had to like see if the fetus was
arriving it's [ __ ] insane like
there's protests about it once more i'm
i myself am of polish origin
uh the the
this isn't like ancient times but like
the family it was around the uh the lev
area which is currently ukraine
uh they are the these uh goran um people
which basically means like mountain
people the
gora i guess
polish is mountain and czech that would
be horror that's that's that's how i
recognize it
all right so poland is batshit uh but
once again since donald tusk or tusk um
percy is back in poland i think he can
lead the opposition to victory actually
so same similar situation as you know in
hungary uh thank you for the question
and the donation uh next is from tim
braun's five euros uh what do you think
about tesla's market valuation compared
to german car makers like mercy like
mercedes and so on oh dude i cannot
[ __ ] wait for the thing to burst
seriously
like uh that bubble holy [ __ ]
it's it's just i mean it's it's it's the
hype around elon musk and like elon musk
has this really strong marketing team i
guess and he's good at marketing himself
i i i would assume
and so the fact that he's such a big
[ __ ] like just just to get back to
the previous question epic bacon fort
funny reddit bro you know tony stark irl
guy
he's making a lot of people rich with
that [ __ ] persona and that's why
that's why it's being pushed because you
know
lots of people want to want to and want
to make and are making lots of money uh
on those stocks which are overvalued
uh thank you for donation so next from
uh chaboharmat
hey adam what do you think will orban be
defeated in 2032 and what do you think
about the whole unity united opposition
uh i answered this question earlier i
think i think the opposition's current
leader who won the opportunity primary
is good he's marketable he's he's a he's
a good guy
and he has a solid chance of of
defeating uh orban in 2020 of april
we'll see but so far the propaganda
doesn't work on him like uh the warband
is trying desperately and he's
propaganda machine they're trying
desperately to
to um
uh pin him on something but he's just
like you know he's a newcomer to
politics he's very good at marketing
he's
clear so
looking good so far i don't want to jinx
it
thank you for the question and donation
so once again from chris das sgd i don't
know what currency is five but thank you
uh would you consider doing a video on
transport and urban planning in
singapore also agree with you enjoy the
principle but i like his psych videos
yeah he's he gives jordan peterson gives
solid psych advice but uh you know
otherwise his political takes are
uh their tool for radicalization
and uh do do you consider a video on
transport and urban planning in
singapore well
i'll have to look into it but i i think
i will extend my reach eventually uh
more and more as time goes on
uh to south america asia
yes so those are those are definitely uh
in the
in my preview i guess
uh five years from philippe chuke thank
you very much uh something what do you
make of the pathetic slovenian eu
presidency
oh dude yeah this does this slovenian pr
yeah well so yeah the slovenian
president is like is like is [ __ ]
insane like that dude is just like it's
just like far out he's doing the [ __ ]
george or jq whatever and he's the
president of the [ __ ]
uh eu currently there's like a rotating
presidency like it's he's not like
elected but you know
yeah crazy times uh very quickly a five
dollar donation from lindsay miss missy
micey uh sorry if i mispronounced that i
plan on moving to europe from the states
what is in your opinion the best place
for a programmer working remotely to
move to like art art plus i like art
plus snow if czech republic i would say
or or
germany even some of the eastern parts
or
any of the nordic countries
right so i think so you should start uh
thank you for donation next from ekka
minhas um we want to make society move
forward
um
but some things need to be preserved to
prevent the french revolution situation
what do you like about western
civilization and think needs to be
preserved well our freedoms need to be
preserved i mean that's that's uh
obvious i think
um
and um
well you know like western civilization
and this is this is like a really like a
big question that i cannot give a
sufficient answer to in just like a few
minutes
but of course like
i'd like to
continue the principles of the
enlightenment
basically that's that's where i'm coming
from here that's the short answer i can
give you right now
um yeah so it's it's basically that
we're like less hierarchy we're not
living under autocrats these sorts of
things thank you for the donation and
the question uh next one from
smith black five dollars thank you very
much how tall are you i'm 184
centimeters tall
i refuse to give the measurements in
burger units
yeah thank you for the question and
donation and next one from ishmael
martin togo
togui
five euros what was your favorite
current european leader um
that's a good question i like this
little the slovakian president uh i like
um
i also like donald tusk of course the
polish guy
um and uh
yeah i guess oh yeah um
what's his name
i i tried to say his name too quickly i
forgot uh oh yeah
the the liberal party leader in the
european parliament he's i think it's
pretty cool
uh he's like the eu's level of g jack
basically we're like the european union
parliament celebration
uh five dollar donation from tom su uh
thank you very much what is your
thoughts on the ccp and the other
workers that's rights abuses yeah
the ccp is like a [ __ ]
tech dystopia at this point so uh i i
don't like them and i don't i i no sane
person no happy saying well adjusted
person should like the ccp they did they
do have some like so some formidable
economic accomplishment
but nothing beside that um like well
like of course well if we don't if we
don't count
you know a tech dystopia as an
achievement um
they're pretty crazy i guess uh they're
like the current chinese leadership is
obsessed with order basically so order
is the only thing
it's literally the only thing that they
that they want to achieve
so
yeah um
i don't like them that much uh a
thousand thousand for inst from just
beeb thank you very much uh these one
with their chiseled apps can't talk it
can't take this anymore cries and jordan
peterson ask lily bogus but exactly i i
yeah
thank you for donation
uh
yes so next no one from uh
yuri craig craitsy i think i'm i'm
freestyling the czech pronunciation
hundred crowns thank you very much uh do
you think v4 that's bishop grad four uh
will break up so bishop four is poland
slovakia hungary and uh
hey check check it out blake i'm sorry
yeah where you're from uh
so uh
yes so the visa glass 4 has become
increasingly irrelevant from now uh now
and uh so bubbish is out so czech
republic that means is out slovakia has
been out for some time now so it's only
hungary and poland so we'll see next
year basically
but i think at this point it's it's just
a v2 so yeah it's it's [ __ ] and
thankfully because you know
it's good for us
uh right so what do you think young
yanoshi thank you for the 420 crowns
damn blaze it
hi what do you think about the recent
czech election i really do any videos on
it uh i don't know if i will uh do a
video about the czech collection but
suffice it to say i'm glad about it so
once again the czech war bond the czech
trump andre babies is now out it seems
to be so that's that's only like that
that's good for all of us that's good
for the world basically
um
so it's it's uh yeah i i i i can only be
happy about that
uh so and now there's gonna be like a
more center-right coalition but with
some with the pirate party in it for
example who are like these progressive
lefty types so that's good that's that's
definitely better than
that the previous one
uh so 100 thousand foreign thank you
very much for the intonation once again
uh a thousand foreigns from chaba
harmony thank you for the super chat uh
do you watch any hungarian youtubers or
do you just watch english speaking
channels uh i i
mostly basically just watch english
speaking once
i sometimes tune into partisan who make
good content but for me that's pretty
much it uh really quickly i i'm gonna go
through these smaller donors before they
disappear um anthony uh
and sorry if i mispronounced it 4.99
thank you very much
i am currently in school to become an
urban planner i recently found out your
channel and love your account any tips
for a beginner keep it up
um right so um
uh to become an implant so do you want
to start a channel or do you want like
advice as a beginner urban planner um
yeah with the channel like i just i
can't like it's a complete accident that
i got popular basically so i cannot
really
say much about that
for for um
uh university just just [ __ ] study
like this
um
uh that's what i can tell thank you for
the donation uh
so next donation from igor points 120
rubles adam greetings from russia thank
you for donation by the way adam
greening to russia and thanks for that
talk uh on ukraine putin who is more
criticized for domestic policies and
their cracks foundation thank you very
much i'm glad you like my stuff yes um
so that's a big big deal for me they put
in a whole protein business
um
once again a small donation before it
disappears uh emp uh five canadian
dollars thank you very much for your
donation uh murdock's on mosque board
worm tongue situation well couldn't have
said it better myself
and uh
now calvin thank you very much for the
69 uh canadian dollars and 69 canadian
cents i guess
um
for all the ads i skipped first heard
about you from well there's your problem
podcast keep up the good work or don't
i'm not your boss well i will keep up
the good work regardless of what you
want me to do um but i guess uh our
objectives align here so i'm glad you
enjoy my stuff so thank you very much
and thank you very much for the donation
that's 69 69.
you know the the the funny number so
yeah thank you
next one from dos man
9.99 uh usd thank you very much do you
do you ride bikes much uh thoughts on
bike culture in the czech republic also
i work with a team from bruno
and i've learned some stuff about it a
video on how planning works i said like
bruno versus the us city uh i like berno
i've been um i i've been there once
though
so i i can't really say that much about
it i i've been to villa togeth
which is this really super nice big
functionalist fellow which now functions
as a museum basically
um so i i do ride bikes by the way like
i depends on the occasion but yes i do
have bicycle and i do use it so i think
it's super useful
and uh bike culture in the czech
republic i think it's getting there
like mainly you just need more bike
paths and more infrastructure for us
more well-put infrastructure and less
core dependence
nobody thinks it's coming along um
right so um
thank you very much once again to dosman
uh next the next superchat is from
chairman of russia damn you didn't know
russia the chairman 9.99 thank you very
much
is there an affordable housing crisis in
europe what about nordic countries what
parts of europe are cheaper is is there
any place where a working classman can
afford an apartment in the city center
oh well
you know to say something like
uh
affordable housing crisis in europe
like in certain parts of europe uh 2
million euros will not get you [ __ ]
and uh okay maybe not 202 million but
yeah but you know i um so suppose you
have like you know quarter or a million
euros like in certain parts that will
get you [ __ ]
and in some other parts that will give
you of get you a [ __ ] half a half of
a town basically so
uh even within germany for example like
in in saxon it's it's [ __ ] insane
like it's it's a you can get an
apartment
in the city in the center of dresden for
like a thousand euros per month
which is the say which is like half the
cost of a berlin apartment which isn't
isn't even near the center
so
it's a very very it very much depends on
the city so but like i would say
eastern european countries are cheaper
east smaller eastern european towns
eastern european capitals have caught up
with with the west basically and the
salaries didn't
but um
uh yeah and like east germany uh that's
this was like former east german it's
also super duper cheap yeah
thank you for the donation uh next one
from email um
us five dollars uh yo what's good for
someone looking to get into video making
in your rough category what is your
video making process
i think the subject i want to talk about
i write down like a little txt documents
and bullet points i expand on them
and i basically i i
i then
just go
go through the talking points uh either
like freestyle on them or or i just like
write down blocks of text that i read
them out it depends and then i i have
the audio and then i just put it in my
video editing software and i basically
just put the imagery on it and then i
produce it so that's that's my process
basically
um
yeah so
no need to over complicate it by the way
like you you don't need to be like a
professional editor to do so
um
right as to thank you very much for the
donation uh toothless
595-499 thank you very much where do you
draw the line
um on the right to bear arms
um
i think well okay so i'm not uh i'm not
a us citizen and to me like
gun culture is like
like wait what like why the [ __ ] do you
need
okay fine like
um
right to bear arms um
like this is i feel like in the u.s it
is so misunderstood because as far as i
know it's it's the this law talks about
like
well-regulated militia uh or like
militias so um i might be wrong guy
correct me someone correct me if i'm
wrong by the way
um so i think it's just like unnecessary
to
bear arms but i guess if you want to
like you can have like a like a gun
permit like it's the same thing it's
done in europe like if you want to have
a firearm then you know you just pass
some tests i guess and you have a gun
permit and so you know
it's basically universal background
checks uh
yeah and then you take your gun to the
shooting range or whatever so you know
if you want to have them cool just you
know don't let crazy people have them
that's all from and i guess that's what
universal background checks are for so
but then again as a european i'm not
really into guns so whatever emma um
um you know i'm just like that
uh next thank you very much for the
donation and the next one from zeal five
heroes i'm from the netherlands uh you
should visit us sometime your channel in
combo with not just bikes made me
appreciate our infrastructure immensely
oh well yeah uh
i'm glad i had that effect on you and
also not just bikes his content is also
super cool i really like him
um
yeah
at some point i will like i'm definitely
planning on going there with my partner
and um
i'm really looking forward to it
actually i really want to see the
netherlands it's very close like from
germany it's like
i think there's like a i'm gonna take a
train from berlin or something yeah
thank you for your donation the next one
from chris dance again uh five sgd i'm
gonna look up what it is
um
thank you very much uh thanks for the
live stream item i look forward to the
next video in two minutes uh have a good
night and everyone in chat well good
night to you too well
maybe not in two minutes but next video
is coming uh at some point soon
um
next question from jack french five
canadian dollars thank you very much
can you admit that elon musk is doing
anything valuable for humanity or do you
just see him as his cynically
self-interested tech bro
i think it's most of the letter like
elon musk himself
is not doing anything
elon musk is not tony stark i think
that's very important too too for us to
to realize
um he doesn't sit in the his [ __ ]
garage under his villa like you know
like putting together the [ __ ] tesla
battery like uh like like tony stark
with or something no he he paid he's
he's like a
he got first off i mean he got his start
from like south african apartheid money
from his parents
and then his like
various i.t projects um and the like
really picked up and then he hired
people who did the work for him uh which
produced stuff like you know spacex and
tesla kilo musk i think he has like a
bachelor's in in mechanical engineering
like he like they do this is
a [ __ ]
otherwise like he's just like he's good
at marketing
i guess but
all the work that is attributed to him
has been done by
just like dozens of people much smarter
and much more diligent than him and i i
don't think he deserves even ten percent
of the praise that he gets
yeah
uh next question for you five heroes
thank you very much um
and let's let me not uh
fall out of the base here um hi i'm from
slovenia and i think that yugoslavia is
the best practice of social and
communities in the world i wonder what
your president are i don't know enough
about yugoslavia actually uh
for me to answer this question sort of
properly i think yugoslavia was
generally um
like of course a successful country
under tito and everything it's a
different question as to how it ended so
i think whether it was successful
um
i think its success also needs to be
considered from the perspective that
there was a [ __ ] you know war
afterwards like
the minute uh things start falling apart
but yeah uh generally i'll i think i'll
look into it more at some point uh next
one thank you very much next one from uh
40 cents thank you very much did i
understand correctly that you lived in
heidelberg once i recently moved here
and this is this city is ridiculously
beautiful love your content thank you
very much yes i lived in heidelberg
slash mannheim for about a year when i
studied there it's super beautiful like
heidelberg is a fully preserved baroque
german city which wasn't bombed at all
it's super good it's
beautiful i really like it so i agree
with that thank you very much for the
donation
uh right next one from
skrizinek
25 polish slots
uh plans for weeds about stupid politics
in poland like how they can build a
bridge over
uh vishla
without any roads leading to it or lgbt
free zones yeah i might actually i might
honor my polish roots and
and um you know launch the poland dunk
series and i don't know maybe i'll
include it in like most likely i'll
include it in a different sort of uh
in like a larger take
on say conservatism or something and and
then poland will be a prime example so
that's what i would expect thank you
very much for the donation and the next
one from
sam vymes once again with the polish
currency 23.99 thank you very much uh
how to prevent suburban cultures quote
unquote in central europe greece from
poland um
i think i don't think eastern europe is
threatened by this sort of suburban
culture i guess you mean like sprawl and
everything and like multiple car
ownership i think tax policies should be
tailored to this like
which
disincentivizes multiple car ownership
because like uh even the czech
countryside i see [ __ ] like
you know someone oh like a family almost
like four [ __ ] cars like uh i've i
think the record i've seen is like
a family owning seven cars it's like
what the [ __ ] this is the czech country
so i was like what the [ __ ]
you know so so tax policy should should
uh be against this
uh in the sense that um
you know um you know you you pay x
amount of tax for your for one car and
for the second car you pay 2x and the
third car 4x like something like that
uh heavy disincentivization also zoning
uh paying attention to debt to house
destiny to density
and um
and uh yeah i think with those uh we can
prevent sprawling like in in in austria
for example this this uh i hear works
well
uh yeah so that's my answer thank you
very much for the donation and the next
one is from jan janoshi again uh 69
check crowns i love your video on czech
city planning thank you for putting
czechia on the map look uh look at the
city of zlin it has interesting city
planning history uh thank you to the tip
zlin yes i'm
i've heard of that place i've never been
there but uh
right thank you for the tip i'm always
looking for new content
uh thank you for the donation
and the next one is from uh um
or what or dollars um i don't know what
currency is that but thank you
uh debbie pereira uh adam uh you're
going to brazil haha i love your content
well thank you i
someone you know someday like i woke up
in a in a cold sweat screaming
at uh
at like 3 a.m
on the floor and then i look at my phone
and it vibrates and there's a message on
it that says come to brazil and from
that point on everything was okay in my
life so
thank you for the donation
uh the next one is from a farewell
underscore fire five pounds thank you
very much um
what is your opinion on shu on head
okay
um greetings from ukraine from ukraine
in london by the way thanks for your
coverage of the war in donbass oh
there's uh thank you very much um for
the compliment and you are going to be
seeing more coverage like i'm going to
cover the whole ukrainian circus in the
near future
in my opinion on shuan head
um
she seems like a nice person i guess but
like
based on what i've what i've
sort of heard
and seen
um she engages in this like sort of [ __ ]
post
politics of like she
just like does the does some like
whimsical things which have some some
rather uh
negative consequences
in the whole political sphere and then
and then she's just like
the like and then the consequent those
consequences come
like uh
bite us all in the butt and then she
just pulls a it's just a prank bro and
like i guess that's it so i i would be a
bit more responsible with her kind of
platform
uh otherwise i think like i've never
talked to her i've never met her she's
like a nice person so you know i just i
just disagree with that aspect of her uh
or a political i guess activity
uh but thank you thank you for five
pounds and uh thank you for the donation
i mean i've got your question but
into doing something
in my oj
i selected my drink to match my sweater
so the next question is from homero
vigne carpi
ars i uh i'm not sure what that currency
is but thank you very much
i'm sorry if i'm outing you but are you
a leftist how would you define yourself
politically socially system et cetera
this is like
u.s 25 cent by the way it's fine thank
you very much
um
no worries uh well
you're not outing me i think it's pretty
obvious that i i'm on the left side of
things
um i would say like a socialist means
like socialist in this case means um
like there's there's lots of confusion
of like socialists sagadam people
interchangeably socialism as far as i'm
concerned means uh workplace democracy
essentially and i am for that i'm gonna
be making a video about that i think i
think that's actually the next the next
phase of capitalism
uh just like how we how we tr how like
feudalism how we sort of upgrade it from
feudalism to mercantile capitalism and
then we upgrade it from mercantile to
modern capitalism i think we should
upgrade to
more it's basically co-op cap co-op
capitalism
uh to contract all the negative
consequences of uh
this economic setup which are
compounding like so now now we're past
the boom years now everyone is feeding
the rain basically on their backs
uh yeah so anyway that's my that's my uh
addition to that thank you very much for
the question and the donation uh next
one real quick from farewell fire again
five pounds to be honest you and it is
kinda okay but
is also kind of everything that is bad
with the american left guns good and
[ __ ] well
you know different people have different
takes on her i guess but uh
i don't know about her gun takes like
if an american says guns good like okay
whatever it's as long as it's as long as
you know as long as they do it
you know within the four borders at home
and whatever
yeah but thank you for the question in
the donation and next one from gombik
for the 200 crowns what do you think of
alexander duke czech's socialism with
human face and the liberalized
liberalization of czechoslovakia during
the prague spring do you think it would
have succeeded with the soviet invasion
i would think yes so so what what's what
gumby is talking about is
this sort of
um loosening up of the of the soviet
um
sort of uh
rather oppressive uh autocritic system
during like the times of soviet rule in
czechoslovakia socialism with the human
face like it was it was generally
better than what was previously
i don't know if it would have succeeded
at this point were just uh this one
would be speculating
but i mean i would guess yes but um it's
it's really hard to tell like those were
pretty crazy times
uh right oh well and the prague spring
was over almost before it began well
it's not true but still uh thank you for
the question in the end the donation
uh next one from
below 27 10 thank you very much what's
your favorite rail youtube channel
oh uh that would be here's a real
youtube channel
i don't i don't i don't think i watch
like exclusively rail youtube i'm sorry
real youtube channels
um
but um
i guess uh i guess rm transit i like his
stuff very much so yeah by the way so
hey subscribe to rm transit is a pretty
cool guy does all kinds of train stuff
so you're gonna get train overload
yeah thank you for a donation
um next one from good vibes storytelling
donating 4.99 thank you very much
donating my daily ammo ration to you
well uh thank you you know i'll
i'll put it to good use
and thank you very much for the donation
uh blur 27 us 10
um what's your oh wait no i i read that
i'm sorry um next one
uh
2440
japanese yen from
naimo nyundo
good morning adam i woke up early in my
saturday morning for this you mentioned
you stayed in tokyo in one of your
videos having implants for videos about
asia
um
well good morning to you too in asia
indeed it is in east asia it is indeed
morning um yeah so um i i did um i did i
did visit tokyo like i
studied japanese and i i know japanese
and i speak japanese et cetera i've been
there multiple multiple times uh i will
go back i really want to go back
actually
i miss the izakaya i actually actually
found like next to next to otsuka uh the
railway station i found this pub where
there was this
where the dude was like a hungarian who
was in like american hungarian who was
the owner of super cool and got lots of
free beer there was super nice um
and um yeah i i am planning i am
planning on uh doing more sort of doing
more uh videos about like east asia i'm
gonna like spread out basically as time
goes on
that's the plan at least
um right thank you very much for the
donation and
we may you have a nice morning next one
from artem um 200 rubles adam thank you
for doing an informative and
entertaining left content i hope my
country russia will overthrow putin soon
well you thank you for the compliment
and you and me both yeah uh hopefully
that will happen at some point uh thank
you very much for the donation and uh
one more from
uh tabio stovak um 100 norwegian crowns
thoughts on how norway are saving their
wealth instead of using more
on their train lines etc they have
promised to upgrade to 250 kilometers
per hour in the whole eastern norway but
keep delaying it
i've heard some
i've heard some
sort of um
i guess
like in terms of norway i've heard
i've heard like about projects of like
these floating tunnels and [ __ ] uh and
like uh road expansions and you know
like i i've heard actually like i've
i've i believe i've seen articles
saying how norway's roads construction
projects actually ended up like actually
netted more congestion
which is i mean it's it's dumb like if
you have all that petrol money then just
[ __ ] just [ __ ] it like just just have
high-speed rail between all cities you
know if it makes sense so yeah
so i think that's a bit like
irresponsible uh
spending all the money but you know then
again i'm not part of the norwegian
government so uh
right um thank you for the question and
the donation uh okay so now we don't
have any super chat so will be returning
to the chat flow
uh i'll see one question from
um
let's see um from seagull satellite
what's your opinion about the planned
breakup of the deutsche bahn in germany
promoted by the greens and fdp
damn this this piece of use just
completely missed me and it's uh if they
do plan on breaking it up
i guess like deutsche bahn is though
it kind of okay so germans will will
crucify me for this but
i think deutsche bank kinda works okay
uh the main reason for it is that is
that like if if you look at first if you
look at how much money the german
government spends
per per country inhabitant on rail per
se like per capita
on rail versus what the netherlands
spends i think there's like a four time
difference like the netherlands spends
four times as much so germany could use
much more investment into rail so i
would guess that's the main issue here
is not the size of the company but
rather funding that being said like
deutsche ban compared to like the
hungarian railways and other other you
know operators produce like provides a
pretty solid service in my opinion
but you know if if the breakup makes
sense then then sure why not
all right so but i got two super chats
here one from huge five heroes thank you
very much uh i meant yugoslavia under
tito and i really think if you dig into
the standard of living in it you can
really
spread the good parts of socialism um
i'll be careful with it because like
this was the same thing that happened in
hungary actually the living standards
the living standards did when i did go
up even in hungary it's it's it's called
uh goulash communism uh that was the
term they used for that era and
the living standards did go up but but
that
whether it was sustainable that was
another issue like in hungary the the
government took out loans upon loans
upon loans to finance to basically
subsidize a non-viable industry and
instead of just like making it more
efficient and actually investing in it
properly
so i just because
living standards rise or that's very
good don't get me wrong it's necessary
but uh
that's i think that's that's only one
metric you also need to look at the like
step back a bit look at the bigger
picture so i would need to get more
information on yugoslavia for me to
uh get more into this but thank you very
much for the uh question and the the
qualification on there the next one is
from count or five euros thank you very
much what is your opinion
on
team seas
team c's they're they're like this uh
i believe they're these like c cleanup
thing right
team
c's
uh
yeah okay uh well yeah so if they want
to clean up the c and that's fine i have
not really read much about them yet
if they do then i guess more power to
them
um
yeah uh thank you for donation next one
from yasmin jeanette varesh
foreign
what is your thousand
city or cities well i would say my
favorite hungarian city
has to be
i would say um
budapest or the one of these two so i
think both are reasonably nice thank you
very much for the donation i really have
to go i'm sorry on the uh through this
super just because they're disappearing
uh next one from dolph the consumer of
reality is 4.99 thank you very much uh
why did you abandon the discord server
it it
i get it's hell but those nerds really
want to talk to you yeah um
i didn't abandon it
i guess i'm just i'm just like busy on a
day to day basis and i cannot always be
there i try i'm good i think i'm gonna
try to actually
get back to it more but like um you know
discussions there on discord don't
usually end up
too productive because then it's just
like it's just i i just end up in this
like tornado arguments but uh i will
increase my presence there eventually
now that's a plan
um thank you very much for the question
and the donation next one from florian
habenicht
5
swiss
gold
thank you very much
thanks for making awesome content have
you ever been to switzerland what do you
think about the public transportation
system here i've never been to
switzerland but
i hear the swiss system is like the
german but much better so
i do plan on going there at some point
actually i i do i really do
uh it's an interesting country and i
like the mountains so uh it's coming
eventually like i'm gonna go and swim
swimming the boarding sea who knows
uh thank you very much for the donation
and the question next one from lorenzo
lorenz zoro's uh five dollars uh why why
people tend to be extremists do you
think that nowadays we have a leak of
pragmatism i think i think extremism
nowadays like today's extremism is a
result of modern conservatism i'm gonna
be making a video about this i don't
wanna spoil um
this subject because it's it's really it
needs to need sound packing
um
thank you very much for the question in
the donation uh next one from juan eusta
del valle
five euros halloweekend from another
european immigrant in germany not only
are you are smart but we know how you're
upsetting and upsettingly handsome keep
up the good work well thank you very
much well
nice to see i next have some compliments
next one from uh christos dokas five
years thank you very much
even if fidesz loses the elections will
it be possible to uproot or even disturb
the whole establishment that has been
constructed in the last years i think
it's definitely possible we'll have to
see there's gonna be a lot lots of hard
work
with that actually hopefully yes
thank you very much next question from
uh mark
bronin uh 100 rubles uh watched your
video about superblocks for me this
looks like a bad and cheap copy of uses
our system system um
micro ion microreinov oh yes the micro
ion system uh in the soviet times well i
think they're basically
like micro ions are as far as i know
constructed
from scratch and super blocks are are
are uh sort of created from what you
have so that's the
that's the the the um i would say the
main difference between those
um
so the uh
so so like uh i think bitcoins are cool
i like them and i think they're really
uh
like they do their job they accomplish
what they what they pla and what they
want to accomplish and um
yeah
uh
but for european inner cities um it's i
think it's uh i think the superblocks
make much more so it's like i mean if if
you have historical city center you
cannot really create a micro iron out of
it um
right if i understand it correctly that
that micro microwaves are not not
like if microns are indeed just built
from scratch but i believe that's that's
what it is
thank you very questioning the donation
uh next one from uh truck and girl uh
five dollars hi from hawaii well hi to
you from europe uh once again i urge you
to take a deep dive into our rail
debacle
hearts 7 billion eyesore i i can help
with research if needed all right if you
have some materials dm me on discord uh
feel free
um
also um
um heart uh that's
yeah i like these american names like
hard scepter bart et cetera yeah well
but you've piqued my interest so please
if you have some materials then feel
free to send me over and send them to me
over on like a discord dm or email or
something and thank you for the donation
i'm sorry i need to drink i'm running
out of steam here
next question from hamid five dollars
what do you think of elon promising to
donate
6 billion to end world hunger to the un
but he needs a detailed accountancy
first isn't this pretentious yeah i mean
it's just
like
oh [ __ ] dude no no no no
okay um so [ __ ] elon musk like he the
story behind this is that elon said like
dude
i'm gonna give you like 6 billion to to
like fight hunger and [ __ ] but
you have to tell me first how you're
going to solve hunger from my six
billion and if you can't do that i'm not
going to give you six billion
and it's like
dude
donations
don't really solve hunger like hunger is
from
from a
hunger is due to
overarching circumstances and
overarching major overarching problems
and a [ __ ] silicon tech bro silicon
valley tech pro [ __ ] throwing money
at it will not solve it if if if um
hunger and poverty and stuff could be
stalled by just donations as some
handcap seems to seem to think then it
would have been solved long ago
um
so you know
it's [ __ ] like because like i mean i
think i think this this might just be a
sort of a sort of bait by elon musk so
you know he's like okay i'm gonna give
you six bill
to solve hunger but tell me how and
they're they're like
we we can't i think it helps a lot but
we can't [ __ ] self hunger with that
and you know's like huh then you're not
getting six billion the deals off i
think if this happens oh my [ __ ] guy
like
yeah as more of the techno [ __ ] tree
of like just like throwing money at it
throwing tech and they throwing capacity
at it and you know the problem will go
away no
this is a child's way of thinking
essentially and um
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway
um
thank you for the donation and the
question oh god don't don't trigger me
like if i if i see another super chat
with like elon musk in it
uh i'm going to launch into this like
50-minute tirade so you know careful
with that thank you so thank you once
again
uh the next question is from black
blackest 33 five videos thank you very
much what do you think about nuclear
energy i think it's the
best solution long-term solar and wind
cannot really cut it for efficiency and
reliability i agree with you actually
i think nuclear is reasonably safe it's
reasonably developed
and it's of course it's zero emission
and we do and we do have
sort of um
adequate uh methods for storing spent
nuclear fuel so as as as soon as that is
that is uh that is guaranteed then i
think nuclear is a good good idea
um so
i think yeah and because of that i don't
really under don't really agree with
like germany shutting down like panic
shutting down its nuclear reactors
because of fukushima you know back in
the day so uh i think nuclear
i'm sorry nuclear could and uh should
have a place in our energy mix
uh right so thank you for the donation
and the question
and we got oh we got just another new
super chat in this moment from farewell
fire five pounds thank you very much
by the way if you need anything
translated from ukrainian or russian or
any qualification on ukrainian russian
politics i've sent you a dm all right
thank you uh i might need that actually
uh so uh we'll see we'll see if that uh
if it will happen actually google
translate does a pretty good job and and
through my check i can also um i can
also infer most of it but if i should i
have any like difficulties or questions
i'll reach out thank you very much for
your offer
right and the uh no super just for now
so i'm back to
the uh oh well there's one super chat
right now
uh
so sorry chatflow
um ix neon two euros thank you very much
any thoughts on musk's new factory in
germany well um
okay fine like i guess he if he wants to
do a factory that he can like it's just
like gonna manufacture
electric cars for rich people
uh we'll see how elon musk handles the
german union laws i'm i'm rather curious
about that
um you know because he's done his fair
share of union busting in the us
so
we'll see in gigafactory what will or is
it a gigafactory next to berlin which is
getting built and whatever
well good luck to him i guess
um
two heroes once again from uh manuel
marie republic thoughts on solipsism
and so solipsism for those of you don't
know is
a um if i remember correctly it's the
it's this it's this philosophical view
that um
that um
everything around you is is um
is sort of just your imagination so
every what you perceive is fully a
product of your of your of your brain
and uh yeah it's a pretty trippy thing
but
it's like
i don't think i would have that sort of
brain capacity but and and but hey even
if solipsism was true and this was all
my imagination like hey cool i got a
built-in vr so you know let's let's go
insane let's go nuts
my brain has some pretty
[ __ ] cool 4k resolution retina you
know so
all right um
so
uh we are now back to the chat flow and
i am
uh
looking through the uh chat right now
um
so let's let me look at a look up a
question once again please add me if you
have a question so i can better see it
[Music]
and there's a i'm looking for a question
which i can actually answer
and uh like meaningfully
let's see uh how i read a book called
how asia works by studywell i do plan
making video about why some countries
are rich another sport i've read
i've read
guns germs and steel i think it's a
solid enough
book in this topic and i've read also
why nations fail which is also i think
is it it's an interesting read so i can
recommend it i don't agree with most of
it i think it's like leaning towards a
bit like neolibi
uh
neolibi um
areas so like i'm suspicious of that a
bit but otherwise i think it's fine what
uh thoughts on youtuber hakeem
um
isn't he kind of like tanky leaning i
don't i don't i've heard of him like i i
don't know enough about him to formulate
an opinion
right so
um
let's see
so what got you into both history and
world politics
it's i just like understanding what's
going on going on around me and uh part
of that is of course understanding
history because
you know as they say
current events form future trends and uh
those and the current events uh have
been formed previously by past friends
so that's history for you okay uh
historians will crucify me for that
and world politics well that's that's
just how how the world works essentially
so i think that's that's i think i think
everyone should
uh be interested in world politics
because that's how our world is
organized
um essentially
all right so um
malarkey asks two dollars do you
consider yourself white
i mean i don't know i'm i'm i'm a bit
brown don't you think i'm like you know
it's just like
i don't know if i would
make the bold claim
uh
me a walking melanine warehouse
uh metal in storage that i'm that i'm
like you know not right so
um
super chat from uh thank you for the
super saiyan
josh judge five pounds thank you very
much uh what's your opinion on rojaba
and syrian civil war in general you
sound like you know about foreign policy
after the wash convo uh i'd like to
think
uh i'd like to think that that
that i know um
like sort of more about foreign policy
than than than uh most people i think in
general like for european foreign policy
i know
i know more obviously
um i think the syrian crime the syrian
crisis was just like
it was it was just assad it was just
young people getting fed up with the
started status quo and then i started
deciding to [ __ ] like shell them with
tanks and then it all went or went south
because of that
um so yeah assad bad rajaba good
um
turkey turkish funded rebels
questionable
um
but but this this this this would be
like the syrian crisis would be like a
[ __ ] two-hour discussion so i'm not
sure if i want to get into it
uh andre to i see your super chat to uh
two dollars do you think thank you very
much do you think georg gargism or
georgia zoom could work in the usa
georgia zoom i think
i don't know enough about georges and to
answer that i
wa the little i know
like based on the little i know
i would say no
but
i
do i i don't feel comfortable just like
giving a flat-out answer to that yes or
no because i would need to look into it
uh
right um so another five but thank you
very much fine video uh
uh super chat from tony mnemonic yeah
thank you very much uh hello from
ukraine i enjoy watching your content
keep it up what are your uh thoughts
about the future future energy um yeah
well thank you very much for the
compliment i think fusion energy uh well
if
not if but of course when they they get
it uh
up and running i think that will be
great
it's like as far as i understand i'm no
nuclear engineer but as far as i know
it's like nuclear but much
environmentally friendlier and safer and
much more efficient so uh that's
as soon as it happens in the next within
the next 50 years or so we'll see that's
what they said 50 years ago that it's
coming in 50 years um
i'm going to be all for it basically so
yeah fusion hell yeah
fusion good
just like trains
and we get another super chat from uh
tone child 50 thank you very much for
the generous donation uh what's your
thoughts on david graber uh have you
have you seen his lectures or read his
books if so what do you think of his
take on history and death
david graber i have to look it up
um
the name doesn't ring a bell but uh
see
uh they don't know everything in user of
humanity [ __ ] jobs oh yeah yeah okay
um
yeah right so so uh
i
have heard of him that the name just
didn't ring any
bells
however i'm looking at the his his
bibliography
yes um yeah so his his uh if i if i
remember correctly then his work his uh
book
[ __ ] jobs was just like uh
uh well basically he's he he's sort of
kind of like laying the groundwork for
stuff like economic democracy if i
understand it correctly uh
might be wrong about that but that's
that's that's why that's how i that's
how i view it
which is based hey i mean that's that's
[ __ ] awesome
uh if he does that uh like i think i
think we do have a problem of of
[ __ ] jobs and just like people not
being invested in the work they done
they just like you know just just like i
like i worked in offices and it's just
like this
soul-killing [ __ ]
um
you know just you just like go in every
single day you
just like
just like type for like
eight hours and then you go home and you
survived and
you do this like every like five times
per week and then at the other they
didn't want to get some like small
fraction you know salary like small
fraction of what the company actually
made
it's not good i don't think it leads to
healthy outcomes yeah but i i will be
talking about uh talking more about this
i think here in the live stream uh once
i'm done with the super chats
or once i have a break between them um
so i got a
super chat for cop i don't know what
currency is uh ten thousand wow from uh
uh honor same what do you think about
the resurgence of left in latin america
especially chile colombia and peru also
high from colombia
um oh this must be what colombian pesos
hmm thank you um yeah so that's good
that the left is resurging there uh
that's obviously a uh
like positive as long as it's not the
authoritarian style you know uh who say
they are leftist and then they just like
turn the country into a [ __ ]
oligopoly
uh like oligarchy with a with a bow on
it um yeah so other than that if they
are if their hearts are in the right
place if they do the right things then
[ __ ] yeah
i support it
uh next one from um voidsec
100 crowns thank you very much any
thoughts on the left and veganism being
linked closely together to each other
well i guess it's it's um
well i uh
it's it's actually it's a good
observation yeah
i guess
the reason why
the left and sort of veganism are
intertwined is because
i would say on the left you see more
inherently humane
ideas than on the right uh so you know
uh basically it's just
okay so just just to put it in in like
uh just to condense it really
uh the
uh like
you know there's there's two buttons in
front of you you know be a dick don't be
a dick and uh
the right
prefers to press you know the be a dick
option on the left prefers like in
general like just
uh most of the time anyway
the other one and so you know not not
harming others not [ __ ] with each
other um
being against hierarchy i mean this this
correlates i guess with with veganism
and those and its ideas
uh yeah so thank you for for the
donation uh next one from tabias tobac
500
nordic norwegian crowns
do you think we will stop global warming
going too far so much is supposed to be
achieved by 20 30 which is only eight
years away by now i don't think so
i think we will uh we will uh run into
the red
the question now is how much will run
into the red
so
you know the what was it the
there's the magical barrier like 1.5 or
2 degrees like if we cross that then
we're basically like you know there's
gonna be some
some
interesting events
um
going on but uh hopefully that that's
that hopefully that will not come to
pass
i don't know if i don't know if it will
if so then you know then then that's
that's that's that's so that's the way
we live from now then that's what we
need to adapt to we will adapt i think
but it'll just it's just going to be
unpleasant it'll have all sorts of
unpleasant consequences
uh in the end so that's that's not nice
uh
yeah so that's why i answer actually uh
thank you very much so the next one
comes from josh judge josh judge um five
pounds uh
well just chris i'm sorry um
um turkey even directly funded al-qaeda
in syria and most of their four proxy
fighters are ex-isis and al-qaeda
uh from other jihadist groups yeah i
mean
like if you're looking for a supporter
of turkey or at least erdogan's politics
and their erdogan's local geopolitics um
like that person is not me i don't like
erdogan uh i like turkey i like turkish
people but not not here the current
leadership is a trash fire
yeah so thank you for your donation uh
next one from speed junkie uh
25 is lodge
polish
uh that is a huge fan i have a civil
engineering bachelor's transport
management masters environmental
engineering masters and i can't get any
job at all anywhere in the eu
any advice
well i mean if you have like if you have
you know a bachelor's master like in two
masters then
i suppose i would get like
it's usually it's it's a language
problem so like if you want to say go to
germany then the first thing they're
going to ask you is like yeah do you
speak german and
if not then then there's no chance so i
i would say i would just like zero in on
a
certain area and then you know just know
the language fully and have some kind of
certificate about it and then go
so but i don't know your situation so
please so it's just like
please keep it in mind that i i don't
know your circumstances
uh that's
that's uh that's one of the ideas you
should consider but thank you for the
donation
uh the next one comes from uh name your
new
or uh
japanese yen uh sorry for my impossible
impossible for white people to pronounce
brumi's name earlier no worries i'm
trying my best here and now i love your
videos um
how do i think of
how do you think of japan's rightful
government
oh god kanji [ __ ] i should i should
really i should really uh rehearse my
japanese yeah yeah testing my nihongo
exactly
um
uh
yeah so
uh i need to brush up on my kanji like i
can i can speak fine but but when you
put kanji on me i just like
i just like start screaming and then
burst into fire so anyway um
right so
japan japan's right in government i mean
i just i mainly uh like i think the
biggest issue in japan of course is with
population
um like i think the the government will
have to like that that's the biggest
thing like the population is declining
and the economy is sort of like with it
so they will uh and the biggest hot
topic issue right now there is basically
just like immigration
so that's that's what they need to
figure out uh which they they have been
sort of moving towards a more centrist
position on this which is good um
i don't follow japanese politics that
hard though so don't really keep that in
mind
uh actually i haven't even spoken really
japanese like live with someone for like
two years jesus christ i do really brush
up on it anyway thank you for your
donation
uh next one from yush five years thank
you very much also please could you give
us slovenians a voice because we have a
very similar situation with our pm
yancha as uh hungary and poland
please we are fed i guess doing fed up
yes uh
well you know it
i will i might i don't i don't i don't
want to say i will but i might you know
evolve slovenia in one of my upcoming
videos um especially about conservatism
there's lots of dumb folks in the world
i can i can involve in that
um
so uh yeah that's what i'm going to do
uh i might like once again i i don't
know how the creative process will play
out i'm
pretty spontaneous with that
um but uh
yeah uh main thing is vote like always
go and vote it doesn't matter if if the
like if if the opponent is like
yoncha light the that or young shalit
that's still better than your shop 100
you know
so uh just vote vote vote uh and uh
eventually you'll get rid of him so
that's that's the uh
you know every country nowadays suffers
its little mental breakdowns we all have
our moments so you know
keep the faith keep the hope brother and
thank you for for the donation and the
next one is from uh
jorgentine uh
right four pounds and 49 pence thank you
very much
do you believe authoritarianism and the
left are incompatible and similarly oath
is only
held by those with bad intent also ban
pablo maybe um
actually i think of course both sides
can be authoritarian both the left and
the right
tankies are great great example of
authoritarian leftists
i suppose
uh nowadays of course the authoritarian
right is more prevalent
uh they are much more uh vocal and they
have much more political power so um
yeah i guess i guess that that might
give some people the impression that
that there's no such thing as like
leftover terrorism there definitely is
and we should fight against it i'm a
left libertarian so you know
at least if i wanted to box myself in
onto the uh political compass thing
yeah so that would be my answer thank
you for the donation
uh next one from richard huffman 25
thank you very much
um thank you for your continued support
of the great cause of trying to make
things suck less well
i guess you and i are both welcome i
think we should both make things uh
suck less
because that's good for both you and me
um
and thank you once again for the
donation and the compliment
uh the next super chat is from
hank shen
five dollars thank you very much uh yo
why do you hate my bro elon bro i don't
want to sit in a pod without a
poor
person sitting next to you a poor person
uh sitting next to you also are you weeb
it's okay if you are i don't think i
qualify for a weeb anymore i i do watch
a lot of i i suppose i did watch a lot
of jojo and i and i have a bunch of like
jojo manga and stuff and i did buy my
fair share of mangoes when i was in as i
was in japan
um
but um
um yeah so that's really weeb and about
the elon
thing i
yeah i might not like elon musk a lot i
don't know like it's just this is the
feeling some people get when they listen
to me so
thank you for the donation
uh the next one comes from hackland oh
one of my mods on discord welcome
hackland
uh 10 pounds no questions just a small
donor and the hello from your discord
server well hello back i i might even
come and visit just kidding i i have it
open right here actually
uh thank you for the donation and keep
up the good modding work i'm really
proud of you
son
we're not related by the way uh so
um next superchat comes from onh
five dollars ideas for convincing local
government to install protected bike
lanes they argue there isn't enough
demand as very few use the death cutters
we do have
well i guess what you need to do is uh
like i i don't know i don't know your
local situation i don't know what would
convince you or a particular local
government
i guess an angle i can think of
is um
for example
um
saying that okay look
uh
it like the current system is bad that's
why no one is using it so let's make it
better so that people will use it you
know it's like saying that
um like just just like some some good
parallel would be nice which they would
understand i don't know what they like i
don't know what they do you know if they
say if they like golf or something you
know those those uh i don't know if
you're from america or something i guess
you are
if they're like golfing with their with
their buddies and then then you say hey
imagine if there was like a really
shitty golf course like just like bring
in an
analogy which they will understand that
they can empathize with i think that's
how that happens a lot usually so like
you know imagine if you had this like
really bad shitty goal of course
and then no no one is playing and then
someone
you know proposes to make a better goal
of course and you say you know but no
one's playing on this but of course not
dumb assets maybe not maybe don't call
them dumbass
but uh you know you can set them off of
course not because it's the current one
is bad so let's make it better so i
would say a vivid and and easily
understandable marketable
um
uh i guess uh analogy uh
should be helpful but once again i don't
i don't know your local circumstances i
and this is just one of one of my ideas
but thank you for the
donation we got another super chat from
jan janoshi conor crowns how do you
explain the sudden absence of left-wing
parties in in czech parliament
will the absence of
absence create more extremists in the
future is
if
gssd doesn't come back i don't know if i
like cssd necessarily like uh
like um the way i understand it they are
part of this like sort of old guard
which
which was part of the reason why we got
i know like this reactionary
uh right-wing party um so cheers says
they like
just because just because a party calls
itself leftist that doesn't tell that
that doesn't mean that they're
automatically good and as far as i
understand it css day is not
uh
it's it's not a party if if he like it's
not a party would vote for
so chia says they actually wait didn't
didn't she essentially hang on a second
oh no
she says
um
because i
called it on she said oh yeah so these
these people actually were were in
coalition
um
in coalition with with uh with oh no
like the reactionary right-wing party so
if this is the kind of leftist advocacy
then like
you know it's
aligned with the reactionary rights
that's not you know
so i am i do want to see
more left-leaning parties i but i don't
think gssd i think is the right answer
now if they are the only or the only
alternative to alternative to some kind
of like far right idiocy like the s
payday
um then sure i'm gonna vote yes they
would otherwise know
but thank you for the question and the
donation at the superjet i mean and the
we got one from um quintin lowman for
five us dollars thank you very much uh
how many languages can you speak as a
monolingual american myself is there any
advice you can give up for learning new
languages um right so well currently
let's see of course hungarian english
german
czech
um and japanese so currently five
officially but of course there's there's
of course the other part of it like if i
really want to like i can kind of speak
and understand slovakian as well so but
i don't think that counts actually
uh so yeah currently i speak five
languages
as far as like how you can learn it um
to start a dueling duolingo figure out
what works for you and then just like
sign up for for some kind of like online
language course or something it's just
like a language school but online
there's plenty of those things or just
go in person
uh for me that's that's what works just
like in my free time i do for example
duolingo and then i go to the language
course which will actually systematize
my knowledge in my hand ahead a bit
better so that's what you should do i
think
um thank you very much for the question
and the donation
uh next one comes from
uh yush once again for five years thank
you very much uh last thing i want to
say tonight why do you think
um
people have lost solidarity for each
other and how can we regain it thank you
for being awesome well thank you very
much for the compliment any donation um
let's see uh people have lost solidarity
for each other i think what you mean if
i correct me firing but i think i think
you refer to this general sort of uh
this general like growing distance
between people like uh throughout our
you know in our day-to-day lives
now that i attribute to to basically uh
what i've talked about earlier in on
this live stream basically
um just just like the the atomization
forces of
modern like of like late stage
capitalism essentially and our uh sort
of anti-social urban planning
and um some other factors perhaps which
is which i'm not mentioning right now or
which i'm skipping but yes um
basically just we need to figure out
like we need to figure out ways to think
differently about our economics how we
how we think of capitalism
and uh we should plan our plan our
spaces our cities in a way that they
they um
you know that they promote more sort of
natural human contact you know so you
know dldr return to monkey no i'm just
kidding um stan thank you very much for
the question uh next one is from juniper
blue lake five pounds thank you very
much hi adam show jojo manga please
i'll show you in a bit once i'm done
with the second um and the other super
chat here from joey
veganer uh 499 usd thank you very much
what do you think of the next face of
the progressives
it is in america considering the fact
that bernie probably won't run for
president in 2024.
i hope there will be a strong candidate
which is more marketable i think bernie
was was was a cool candidate but like
it didn't really help that he was like
500 years old so um i think if they do
if they get that in you know if they get
um
a sort of marketable reasonably
progressive etc candidate in uh
who's who's who basically who's like
barack obama but like not as neolibe and
actually does what he promises then that
would be super nice i think that's
possible
uh right so anyway we'll see we'll see
how that will happen we still have three
years left thank you very much for your
donation and the question and as i
promised once one second um i'm gonna
guess one of the mangas to show you
uh in the meantime you can look at the
cat the kitty cat
who's sleeping now so be quiet be quiet
okay
oh she's up okay
yeah so here's here's one actually oh
this is actually in english i don't know
i don't know
oh yeah this is this is the one i
ordered when i was just like starting to
to
what i was just like starting to study
japanese but i really like jojo even at
that point so but like of course at that
point i didn't understand in japanese so
i was just like okay i'm just gonna get
it in english so i can understand it i
also have a whole bunch of them in
japanese but they're not here currently
i i left them in hungary so uh
i should i should bring them around
probably here at some point
uh right
and i get i have a super chat in the
meantime from john wagner uh five
dollars thank you very much uh what was
the situation when the cabin in the
cabin where the officials and oligarch
were found i can't find anything about
it and i forgot the involved countries
oh yeah you're referring to the uh the
the community post i made uh
about um
i'm sorry
about uh the slovakian former pm getting
caught in this like hunting lodge with
some oligarch and a lawyer and whatever
yeah so it was slovakia and it was
robert fitzoh who got caught there
and uh yeah it was pretty [ __ ] insane
um
yeah so for the for more information
like refer to my community post or just
try to google the names i think it will
come up because because it was it was
like a rather resonant and funny
incident
so yeah
yeah [ __ ] so uh the slovakian orbon
anyway
there's there's some other super chats
here which uh
[Music]
which
kind of got lost just one second
um
manuel maria de uh republic asks uh in
two two years thank you very much uh
would love more content from you podcast
maybe
and not in the works yet we'll see if i
if i burn out at some point and i decide
that i want to you know
do the
the uh
uh you know the podcast format i think
that's that's what h3h3 did and it
worked out for them uh i'm not there yet
sort of creatively
so we'll see anyway i'm keeping my
options open of course uh superchat we
got from uh lin chalu a thousand
hungarian foreign
thank you very much uh what are your
thoughts on the state of education in
hungary or global in general what are
the consequences if if this downward
trend continues uh i would say the
hungarian education system is like
you know it's hungary basically did what
what people were afraid donald trump
would do which is patriotic education
and it is like a long-standing problem
like we had patriotic education for a
long time
i also got patriotic education
and it was it was ass like i i had to
basically learn the true version of
history um from from from other sources
essentially
um because i got thought i just got
thought this like
this like
[ __ ] oh my god kitty why are you
crying
anyway
cat is noisy
yeah so i think it's i think it's
definitely the problem i think um just
like
better funding better organization and
just like no patriotic education would
like this would be already like 80 of
the work
needed
uh anyway
oh and i got a go go go go
jojo
menacing
super chat for 250 yen thank you very
much
i don't actually see the
the
smaller donors
on top
i think the minimum minimum amount for
that is i think around like four dollars
or so for 54.99
uh if you if you send donos which are
like um
which are less than that then i
i need to scroll through the chat to see
that so there's no guarantee that i'll
see it but i'll i'll try my best still
uh
and of course those are also very much
appreciated um but i got a ten dollar
super chat from uh
tone uh tone child uh thank you very
much uh what are your thoughts on the
neon projects in saudi arabia with the
neon project
maybe i know it's
uh a different name
neon
oh the cross-border city of southern i
want
oh
god okay okay i i've read the first two
sentences as the first two sentences and
i already know what this is about
okay
okay so this this um how wait how come
how come we haven't heard of this that
much actually this is super super
interesting like i i didn't
the name like barely wronged a bell
uh whatever uh
it looks pretty [ __ ] stupid just like
the line and any of these like
smart city future whatever like
these like petrol dollar fueled you know
delusions that these people have
well thanks for a tip i will look into
it and i i might
actually incorporate it in a video
because i am looking for more stupid
children from the middle east as well
since you know
i i might have made a video about a
certain um
golf state which kind of got relatively
popular
anyway
so i'm back to reading the chat flow now
um let's see oh my gosh science adam
something hello from belgium the last
the last european country with
compulsory voting what are your thoughts
on the matter voting right or voting
duty
uh
that's a
that's a good question actually i would
say
i think it i think we should we should
of course get people incentivize people
heavily to vote
uh
and but i i don't think i would do it
like on a compulsive basis i would say
okay
if you vote and if you can prove that
you voted then you know you can
you can [ __ ]
like have a have more tax credits or
something something like that uh
something like incentives to uh uh
one second
[Music]
some like incentives to vote i think
that's healthier than than just to just
to mandate it because that's just uh
rather
yeah okay kitty ready for the next
question
so
uh next super chat is from um
frost throne
uh five swiss franc thank you very much
saw the guy here uh neom is basically
dubai 2.0 well
yeah i looked at the pictures that that
much i suspected actually
um
now what's this weird noise on my camera
seriously anyway so it's supposed to be
a 1080p full ad webcam and like
something it's not
i thought you had something to say but
she doesn't
uh back to the super chats
kitty would you like to read super chats
or would you like to go play
all right i'll put you down
ah there you go
so i'm back to super chats
um
from uh mark cronin again uh 200 rubles
thank you very much
uh so you said that russia has only oil
and nukes but because uh because of the
sanctions it can't export anything else
russia actually have a lot of big tech
companies rocket technologies
supercomputer cpu
yeah they might but that that still is a
a sort of smaller
uh smaller percentage of their overall
economy like to to like the reason why i
said that like russia is a petrol
monarchy with with nuclear weapons is
because that's what they are
uh like that's what most of their
economy is based on so it's not it's not
this like sort of healthy diversified
economy but rather
it's more of this like mono economy of
like they base there they base their
their wealth on this like raw materials
export heavily
so yeah that's that's uh
that's actually uh that's why i use that
terminology
and uh the next super chat is from
lemontree one 499 no text included but
still thank you very much for the
donation
and some smaller super chats too uh from
kakira watts
to us dollars
what do you think about maglev train
technology well i think i think i
covered it partially at least in one of
my videos uh one second
um
like maglev trains are nice
but um
but uh
like it's just they just don't make that
much sense in very very specific
scenarios they
they they do
but uh
but for example in in japanese in japan
with the chi washing constant between
tokyo and osaka like that makes sense i
guess and if they have the money then
fine
and uh oh
oh
another kitty is trying to jump up but
that's not going to happen
um so i think maglabs do have their own
sort of um
i guess niche application but but that's
the problem it's it's just mostly niche
application there's no way to
really
sort of like
put like
build maglev's
um
just uh just on a mass mass scale plus
plus i i believe the tracks eat a lot of
[ __ ] copper
uh so it's it's it's it's really like a
just a hassle to uh to build it as
opposed to having like two steel beams
on some concrete sleepers
so um yeah
i think maglevs are not the the
solution they might in some cases
but those cases i don't think
i don't think it's it's um
i don't think those cases are worth
uh the scale of investment and the hype
that we have so you know i think if
japan did some kind of like high ultra
high speed whatever conventional rate i
think they would have similar results
anyway um so longer longer story i you
know once again mug left niche
applications they're fine
and i have a another super chat from
owen h5 thank you very much
can free markets compete with command
economies in the modern era also what
are your thoughts on deliberate economic
de-growth
well command economies
so anarcho-capital like end cap
economies and commanding
economies are like the
insane ends of the spectrum the opposite
insane ends of the spectrum uh i would
say so i think they would be equally bad
and it would just be a race to the
bottom essentially
and deliberate economic degrowth um
like
degrowth to like degrow the economy it's
like okay if
even if you even if you
can sort of uh
okay so
in in terms of degrowth even if you sort
of uh
i'm not informed enough about this but
but if i understand it correctly sort of
strategically d strategically
contracting the economy in certain ways
for
good certain good outcomes
uh you know i think that's that's the
way i understand it if it's if it's
[ __ ] then please call me out right i
don't want to spread misinformation but
i think d growth would be
like the main problem is like how do you
sell it to people nobody intended so hey
here's this here's this
idea like okay here's the plan
we're gonna do this thing
and you're going to live like
measurably worse you're going to be
worse off economically but hey for this
common good like you know like
in like in the us we're struggling with
[ __ ] universal healthcare like how
like do you think people will follow
this so i don't think this is i don't
think even if a d growth is viable which
i don't know if it is
i don't know i don't know enough about
it
even if it is viable there's like a
thousand things in front of it which we
should be doing before the growth you
know before we can even get there so i
don't think i don't think proportionally
it's worth to to spend so much so much
uh
uh
time or or energy discussing it so it
might be a fun sort of psychological
i mean philosophical experiment but
not more than that
um another super chat from yan yanoshi
thank you very much 100 crowns i i think
losing chess as they would be a loss
it's the oldest czech party
1878 plus
now plus i talked about zlin it's
basically usa style city big part of it
was built in the 30s it might be
the most car centric city in the czech
republic okay
then i'm going to look into it uh sports
of the czech republic also tend to be
sort of bizarrely car centric i don't
really like it
but
but uh if if the deed is indeed that
then then that might actually be worth a
visit even i might i might actually
parachute myself down down to the ground
and uh
you know just like
uh snap my fingers and like disappear
half the city whatever
thank you for the question and the super
chat um i'm now back to the by the way i
i'm on for about like nine more minutes
uh i plan this to be a two-hour stream
so if you have any questions any super
chats that you want to submit then do so
in the next nine minutes
and because around at around
midnight cet that is in eight nine
minutes i'm going to uh i think i'm
going to be cutting the stream and going
to sleep
um
i've been up since like i don't know 6
a.m or something right so um
super chance from uh mark uh protein
again 100 rubles thank you very much
oil is only a small part of russian in
our economy less than 10
most of economy actually based on around
services and production um
okay uh the uh the economy uh that's one
thing but i think i think uh
i was talking about exports
so
like to to what extent uh plus like
foreign currency revenue it's always
complicated but like the point is like i
don't know the exact numbers in front of
me i could look to know
uh but now i i don't have the time
uh but um the point is that
uh russia is like russia's export and
like access to foreign currency as far
as i understand it is more dependent on
on um
sort of essentially selling its fossil
fuel uh right like hence the current
energy crisis in europe i mean that's
that's also partly caused by russia like
because europe is dependent on russian
gas
and with that russia gets access to huge
sort of foreign currency
uh
um
you know
cash payments well not cash but yeah
payments let's just leave it at that
but yeah i agree i agree that that
russia is like the internal economy at
least is not of course of course it's
not not uh
that's fossil centric it usually has to
do with export
all right
uh right and we have a donation from
tone cha thank you very much by the way
uh and we have a donation form
tone child uh 40 us dollars thank you
very much it's a big number uh congrats
on 500k subscribers uh thank you uh what
are your plans for the future of your
channel uh well i'm just going to keep
doing what i do because i enjoy it and
by me enjoying it i think you guys also
uh enjoy it too so i think i think
that's that's it that's a healthy
that that's the healthy dynamic when the
with the content creator like the
content creator should
enjoy making their content and because
of that the audience will also do so you
know so if i just made content just
i guess just i have to i have a channel
hey guys
adam something here and today we're
gonna oof like cities aren't they crazy
wow lots of lots of buildings right oh
cars oof like you know
so i think that's that energizes me
and you as well so you know it's just a
pleasant like a more pleasant
um
you know uh experience uh thank you very
much for the uh edition and the donation
uh next one from tom sue uh five dollars
do you think that's the extreme cultural
conservatism of east asian societies is
directly related to traditional chinese
confusing confucius doctrine
i am not well worse enough in
confucianist doctrine to to answer that
question
i think each country has its own fair
share of of
of um self-historical background and uh
and uh sort of uh local prejudices and
racism etc i know that like you know
japanese and chinese et cetera like they
can be super racist especially
especially towards like uh people with
darker skin and the like
um
it might just be because
might so i'm speculating here but like
my educated speculation if there's such
a thing
would be that uh
like for example in in china and japan
people just like don't really encounter
different people on a day-to-day basis
or at least not in that quantity and not
the appropriate circumstances
which would help with the lowering of
prejudices so i think this might be an
issue but of course like each country
has its own
set of issues so you know that's how
that's how it'd be
thank you very much once again uh so one
from dead meme uh super chat what do you
think of the dubai video in particular
going viral if you could have picked any
other video to go i would go viral
instead which one would it be
i'll be honest it completely surprised
me that the dubai video went viral like
i did not expect it at all
um
and um it was it was pretty fun like of
course like
it was so trippy
because you have to understand
um
i was when i did when the dubai video
came out i think i was around like 30
000 like 50 000 subscribers or something
and
from like 30k i went to 350k
in like a week or like two weeks i was
like what the [ __ ] is oh my god
you know i i felt like i don't know like
a a squirrel strapped to a to a rocket
you know which is
about to go which is about to enter
orbit
um
which pretty much what happened yeah
that's what it was basically
and um
yeah so it was super nice although like
the the video like it's so it don't get
wrong it's very it's very very good the
the the dubai video went viral
um because dubai is up to some heinous
[ __ ] and i'm also kind of tired of like
people just like edulating over dubai
like
oh my god the the incredible i know it
sucks shut the shut the [ __ ] up now you
don't you don't know what what's
involved there like the slavery and [ __ ]
and um
i'm glad about it i guess
the
the
video
um
the video uh
i want i would have wanted to go viral
the most
i would say is my video about the
refugee crisis
currently titled how orban betrayed the
west i think i'm going to change the
title again because like i'm looking for
titles that will like catch some more
attention uh because um you know i i
really want that video to be watched and
that's my only video which is not
not really watched by that many people
it's pretty frustrating but anyway
you can't always have everything um
quick really quick like uh thank you
very much once again for the donation
and the question uh remark north uh
50 danish crowns and what do you think
about eu core versus your perimeter
issue and wealth inequality on this
macro level uh well nothing we cannot
fix with some good old-fashioned uh
cohesion funds and economic democracy i
believe uh this is something that we can
and should address otherwise this will
just come back and buy this in the bot
you know like having this sort of
so-called two-speed europe where one
group of of member states advance
at a certain rate and then there's a
different part of europe which is kind
of like falling off because they don't
advance at that and that's high rate so
this is something that we definitely
should solve otherwise otherwise you
know
the eu's uh future would be a stake and
i believe
um thank you very much for the question
so the next one is 20 euros potax man
and thank you very much for the donation
i'm happy for the content you create
keep uh keep your openness uh thank you
well i'm glad you enjoyed my stuff and i
will a question thoughts on the ethical
use of technology aeg facial recognition
ai et cetera and what about the role of
the government i think this is like this
is the role of like facial recognition
ai et cetera like this is not something
i would leave up to private companies
like
it's it's you i think you would end up
with something similar as like what
china has with their horrible [ __ ]
like dystopian social credit system
but instead of the chinese government
it's it's [ __ ] it's it's the it's the
mosque empire you know like or the besos
uh the ibiza was monarchy some horrible
corporate dystopia like that i think i
think um
like
since i'm european i don't have this
sort of like uh visceral emotional
reaction to like government you know so
um
basically
uh i want a
was a well-run government in charge of
some sort of vital
um
pieces of technology or or services
which could
sort of spiral control really quickly if
if left to
the hands that only seek profit for
example the corporations or
those who only seek power like like
dictatorships uh and like so
i would say
i would say uh that is the uh that is
the um
that's my perspective on that but thank
you for the question and the donation
next one once again from uh mark pruden
um
i'm so sorry
200 rubles only reason russia dependent
on oil is because it's forbidden to
export anything else it's like beating
up someone and then saying that his
bones are broken like russian economy
no not really
russia can import like what russia can
still export
to
of course they cannot export or at least
countries get will not accept
exports like in europe or or america and
like allied countries
uh yeah for that too
okay so someone's like beating up
someone
okay so why did the sanctions happen
though
uh because russia kind of invaded a
sovereign european nation like in the
dumbass and in in like in the annexed
illegally like an annexed crimea
illegally
uh which they like they they signed the
so-called budapest memorandum which
stated that
uh they're going to cede crimea to
ukraine in exchange ukraine will forfeit
all of its nuclear weapons which which
they did and they agreed and then russia
as soon as they could they might as they
put in
he broke that promise and invaded
because like you know [ __ ] it let's be
alleged right so the
so okay sanctions are of of course not
nice but like they're they're they're a
result of something
uh and that's that's the reason
basically
so anyway
this this has two sides and
like as with most issues and here i
think like russia is completely in the
wrong like you you cannot get to like
if you if you i mean you you have to you
have to understand like you cannot get
away
with invading
like sovereign countries in europe in
the 21st century like and if and if this
this was and
if we allowed russia to do this or if we
didn't do anything about it then there
would be more
just like they invaded [ __ ] northern
georgia you know the south asia thing
which which are still to this day
um these like separatist areas which uh
on a sporadically below sporadically
belong to the
georgian government or if if uh if they
belong to it anyway or transnistria in
in moldavia which is another separatist
region which is entirely funded by and
fueled by russia so it seems like it
seems to me that those sanctions do have
a point and they do serve a very very
important purpose
um so yeah
and i would actually i would actually be
for like just like disconnecting russia
from the [ __ ] swift system like the
europe like the payment system
and just like you know cutting like
cutting them off from all the
uh tools and and products of the
of the liberal western world which
russia is against so then you know so
that pressure cannot use
our own
uh our own tools and advancements
against us basically
so that would be my my take on it but
all of this will be covered in my
ukraine video coming out
at some point
right so i don't see any new super chats
so uh
so uh i think uh
right okay so i think this was as far as
this stream will go thank you very much
for tuning in it's two hours
uh long just as i intended
and thank you for tuning in and i guess
i'll be seeing you at one million
uh i don't know when that will happen
and um yeah very good questions so thank
you very much there was really fun i had
really fun answering them
and uh of course thank you for the
donations as well
and
oh well there's one super chat that's
still uh
still uh power slid in i'm gonna read
that out quickly and then
i think i'm going to uh
be
putting myself to rest
so robert friend five pounds thank you
very much uh what are your thoughts on a
unified school system in europe but uh
by that i mean grades curriculum etc yes
i would be in favor of that to some
extent of course the education system
will have to have its own local
local
uh characteristics uh but like i would
say like standard standards are
standardizing to the point where it
doesn't harm quality and it doesn't you
know do any damage locally and but but
to the point where it like sort of helps
european cohesion and and helps people
sort of
move around within the whole common
european area economically so i think
that would be a reasonable thing to do
so um
i think this was the last superchat so
thank you very much and i'll be
uh i'll be going going now
uh thank you for tuning in once again
good questions thank you for your
donations
and
i guess
i'll be seeing you
next time
thank you and have a good night or good
morning depending on how where you are
so
bye people
bye